خالد الشاب والثلاثيني والذي يعمل في محل
لبيع الملابس يرى في قانون خدمه العالم
ضروره لمعالجه مشاكل الشباب وعلى راسها
البطاله ولذي بموجبه سيكون على كل شاب بلغ
18 من عمره الالتحاق بالجيش مع عوده
التجنيد للزامي انا اريد هذا الشيء اليوم
احنا هذا المفروض احنا لازم سابقا احنا
نسوي لهذا الشيء لان دول العالم
هسه احنا شبابنا يعني مع الاسف عندهم خمول
عندهم
كسل بالموضوع وهذا الشيء يسوي ال همم
الشاب همم زلمه
وبنفس الوقت تتوح في كليتها ويصير عنده حس
وطني اكثر
روح موجود مؤيدين للقانون لكن احمد ومعه
اخرين يرون فيه تبديدا لاحلامهم وطموحاتهم
في التوظيف والحياه الرغيده هو طبعا ظنينا
يعني يصيبه احنا كما مثلا خمس سنوات نداوم
الطب مثلا تكمل يعني ضلت تدور والله على
الدوره وتعال تجنيد وما عرف شنو يعني تدور
تريد تعيين تدور مثلا تريد تشوف الشغل
جهات سياسيه تمثل مناطق شمال وغرب العراق
رحبت بالقانون معتبره الخدمه الالزاميه
عاملا لتعزيز روح المواطنه والقضاء على
البطاله لكن الاجنحه السياسيه للفصائل
المسلحه اعتبرت القانون يستهدف نفوذها
ويقلص حجم تاثيرها امنيا في البلاد جميع
الفصائل المسلحه
والمنظمات الاجراميه تخشى وجود جيش قوي
متمكن يستطيع محاسبتها اذا ما خرجت عن
اداره سيطره القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه همم
معنويا همم تصبح القوات المسلحه اكثر
استعدادا وتاهلا لمحاسبه الخارجي
الجدل هنا لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل تعداه
الى سحب قراءه القانون من جدول الاعمال و
تاجيله للدراسه بحسب لجنه الامن والدفاع
النيابيه الانقسام الشعبي بين التاييد
والرفض للقانون انعكس بشكل مباشر على
الكتل النيابيه ما وضعها في حرج من امرها
وربما يجبرها لاحقا على اعاده النظر في
ترحيب مجددا داخل اروقه البرلمان صبري
الكبيسي العربيه بغداد